[MUSIC PLAYING]
TRAVIS MCPHAIL: I'd like to
welcome you all to this Google
Maps Platform talk.
We're going to take a
deep dive into building
for performance and scale.
So I'm Travis McPhail.
I'm one the engineering
leads for the Maps Platform.
Just to give you a
little context about who
I am, since I've
been at Google, I've
worked on a number
of different products
that you are probably
familiar with from Maps
to Earth to Street View.
But even before then, I
worked in various industries
from the special
effects industry.
I worked in gaming, biomedical,
seismic data analysis
in oil and gas, and more.
So in short, I'm
a graphics geek.
But more important than
that, I have a passion
to help people
fulfill their purpose.
In the context of
today, that is to help
each and every one of
you incorporate Maps
into your products so
your users can have
the best experience possible.
Now, before I get into
the meat of the talk,
I do want to do a
little slight recap
and go over the last 12 months.
So last year, at I/O, we
announced the Google Maps
Platform, and we committed
to evolving our Maps APIs
into a more simplified,
more scalable,
easy-to-use set of tools
that meet your needs.
Now, it's been a very
busy year, and we
know that a couple
of these changes
weren't easy to adapt to.
Some of you had to
adapt to new prices.
Others had to make
changes to your code bases
based on changes that we
made to our APIs and SDKs.
But I want to reassure
you that we've
been hard at work for you
to improve the developer
environment for you.
And I just want to give you
a little taste on what's
happened underneath the hood.
So for the past
year, we've really
focused on the stability,
the reliability,
and the performance
of our platform
so that we can guarantee our
99.9% uptime for our SLA.
This helps us continue to
provide over 150 million places
for you and your users.
It continues to allow us to have
routes that cover more than 40
million miles on the Earth.
And it allows us
to serve you maps
that cover 99% of the world.
Some changes that you might
have felt more directly-- we now
offer support
available to everyone,
not just a subset of developers.
We've upgraded our Places
SDK on Android and iOS.
And we continue to invest in
some of our industry solutions.
In particular, we have some
meaningful partnerships
that we've established
in the gaming community
and the ridesharing community.
And great things are being
worked on as we speak.
But on to what we'll be
covering in this talk.
So we're going to go
through a number of things.
I'll try not to go
through it fast.
So please forgive me if I'm
a little speedy on this.
But first, we're going
to dive into performance.
Then after we go
into performance,
we're going to talk a little
bit about data visualization
and WebGL.
And then we'll end it off
talking about building faster
on the Android platform.
So performance at scale.
This section of the talk,
just for everyone in the room,
I'm going to focus on the
web and mobile web platforms.
The reason for this is because
the majority of feedback
that we've received
from developers who've
experienced performance issues
when rendering a lot of data
on top of our maps, they come
from the web community, so
mobile and web developers.
And note that the things I'm
going to suggest on stage
can be applicable
whether or not you
are a mobile web developer or
just a web developer or both.
So one of the main
abstractions that developers
use to render a lot of content
on the map are custom overlays.
So I don't if you're familiar
with custom overlays.
Some in the room might not.
Some on Livestream or
YouTube may not be.
But custom overlays are merely
a layer of geospatial data
that you render
on top of the map.
So imagine yourself being the
owner of a real estate site.
You could render
all the listings
and the property bounds
using the custom overlay.
So what does that look like?
Well, first off,
your custom overlay
needs to extend
our overlay view.
You'll have a constructor.
It may or may not take a map.
More than likely it will though.
There are a couple
of lifecycle methods
that you need to implement.
So there's [INAUDIBLE]
method that you
implement when the
map is actually
ready to use your
custom overlay.
And when the map decides
to remove the overlay,
there's our remove method to
help you clean up the state
that you've accumulated during
the time it's been in session.
But the interesting method
here is a draw method.
And the reason why
this is interesting
is because this method is
called every single time
that we draw the map.
So developers should
take great care
in determining how much
work and what type of work
you do within this method.
So we're going to
talk a little bit,
give you a few suggestions
on consultation
that we've provided to
developers over the years
to allow you to avoid
some of the pitfalls we've
seen from previous developers.
So the first item up here--
do not add and remove
content until the user
stops moving the map.
Just to reiterate
this a bit, the map
experience-- we redraw
that every time the user
moves the map.
So if a user is dragging,
we are constantly
trying to redraw that scene.
And if your custom
overlays are taking a while
to actually complete, that
could introduce some stuttering
or a little bit of lag or
jank into the overall map
experience.
So if you look at
this example here,
this is an example of us
adding content and removing
content on the draw method
regardless of whether or not
the map is moving
or stops moving.
As you can see,
as you move over,
as the user pans the map,
the right side of the map,
it takes a while to load.
It feels a little janky.
And the reason
that's happening is
because we are
adding and removing
content while we're
actually drawing the map.
In contrast, here's an
example where we only
add and remove content
when the map is stabilized.
You can see as we pan the
map renders more smoothly.
And when the map
becomes stationary,
new content is displayed on top.
This leaves for a better user
experience for your end users.
But this type of problem
points to a larger issue.
And the main takeaway
here is do not
perform heavyweight, non-drawing
logic in your draw method
just period.
So when your users are
looking at the map,
they think of the
entire map experience.
And if we want to
provide a very--
solution, we only have
a certain amount of time
to render each and every frame
to guarantee the framework
that we want to show.
And in this graph here, this
middle line represents and 16
and 2/3 milliseconds,
which equates
to 60 frames per second.
The rightmost line equates
to 33 and 1/3 milliseconds,
which equates to 30
frames per second.
And if we take longer than
this to render a frame,
probably going to introduce
some jank to the user.
They'll notice, and they'll
frown, and they're cry.
I'm sorry.
So in general, we do a fairly
decent job for our users,
just the base map itself.
On average-- strike that.
Our median draw time
for rendering a frame
is between 16 and
18 milliseconds.
Some users, for various reasons,
experienced worse performance
than that.
So it might take a little
longer to draw a frame.
It could be due to hardware,
browser version, a number
of items that factor in here.
Some users have a
much better experience
than our median results.
But regardless of
whether or not you
have a user that has a great
base map experience or one that
doesn't have the optimal
base map experience,
we should provide them
with a overall smooth
and interactive map.
And it's not just us that
provides that to them.
But it's also you
all and the custom
overlays that you
add onto the map.
So in your draw method, if that
takes one to two milliseconds,
you're pretty much
guaranteed to have
a very performant
experience, regardless of
whether or not your user
is on a high-end device
or if they have the less
optimal base map experience.
They still have a fairly
decent overall experience.
However, if you are querying
for a lot of content,
making a lot of
changes to the data
that you're showing
within the draw method,
if you're also
possibly manipulating
a lot of dom elements
during this draw call,
you could introduce a lot
of time in your draw method.
And although you may
have some users that
on a very high-end device that
you might have a performing
experience on, there
will inevitably
be users that don't have that
same experience and experience
jank.
So please help us.
Together, we can provide
a more useful experience
for your end users.
But as we've talked to
people, talked to developers,
and got a general sense on how
people use custom overlays,
we started to find
that our markers API
could solve a lot of the
use cases that we saw.
And this also has the added
benefit that you as a developer
don't have to worry
about making a performing
implementation on rendering
a lot of content on the map.
That responsibility
can be placed on us
and free you up to
do other things.
But a lot of developers are
aware of different market
performance characteristics.
So we're going to walk
through an example
where I add 1,000
markers on the map,
and I can show you
how small changes can
lead to some large
performance implications.
So we'll start with
a little bit of code.
This is just a method
that takes lat-long bounds
in a number of
points and creates
that many number of
random lat-long locations
within that lat-long bounds.
I use this to make 1,000 points.
In this demo I'm about to
show, I initialize the map.
I create a marker four all
1,000 of those locations.
And I use it an SVC
asset for the icon
because everyone loves SVGs.
And I also add
mouse over a mouse
out listeners to toggle the icon
as the user pans over the map.
So here's an example.
Here's an example.
These are markers
over Australia.
And I will note
that I'm actually
trying to zoom into the map.
And there's just a large
lag in the experience.
So I'm panning around, just
showing that there's actually
a couple of seconds delay
between my user action
and the drawing of the
results on the map.
All right, this is making
me cringe a little bit.
So you're probably saying,
what gives, Travis?
You told me that you're going
to show me an example where
you render 1,000
markers on the map,
and it's a great experience.
It doesn't like you
added a lot of code.
What gives?
So there's one line in this
that I want you all to look at.
It's this lovely SVG asset.
I'm just going to
make one change.
We're going to
change this to a PNG,
and we're going to
rerun this demo.
So now if you run this demo,
you have a much more performant
map.
It follows my user
gestures pretty well.
And the performance
characteristics of this demo
completely changes.
And the reason behind this is--
for right now, please
use JPEG or PNG assets.
If you are using SVGs, try
to rasterize them first.
It's just more effective and
more efficient in general
to render a raster
image for the user--
I'm sorry-- use a raster
image for the icon
as opposed to an
SVG representation.
But as an aside, what
I'm talking about,
raster and vector,
when I took this job,
one of the product managers
in the organization
told me that there
are some developers
that innately feel that because
we offer a raster-based maps
experience through our APIs that
somehow that means that it's
inherently less performant
than if we went with a vector
graphics solution, maybe
like a WebGL offering.
So I wanted to put a
little data to that.
So if you look at one of
our raster-based products
that we offer, which is
a Progressive Web App
version of Maps, it is a
raster-based experience
that we at the Google
Maps Platform power.
And the median FPS
across live traffic
that we've analyzed for a
while through various actions
is around 55 milliseconds.
Contrast that to if you
go to maps.google.com
on a device that
supports WebGL, you
get a complete
WebGL-powered experience,
but the median frame
rate for that experience
is around 51 frames per second.
So this is not to champion
or knock either platform.
We provide both
options within Google.
But we save the WebGL for
the consumer experience.
But this just serves
that whether we
serve you a raster-based
implementation
or a vector-based
implementation,
you will have a performant
base map to build your web
applications around.
So back to our example,
if you look at this map,
I don't know about you,
but if you want your users
to interact with the
individual contents
that you add on top of
the map, it's hard for me
to decipher any meaning on
the content that we're adding.
Because there's 1,000
markers on Australia.
I can't even see the
majority of Australia.
So one last note--
don't forget to cluster.
We have a marker cluster
support library that we offer.
And in my demo example
here, I use that in order
to cluster content
on the map again.
So there are a couple of
options that you can use.
There's a grid
option size, which
controls the amount of markers
that would cluster together
into one group.
There's a maximum
zoom, which controls
the maximum zoom
level, after which you
shouldn't see clusters.
And then you can
provide an image path
that has the base URL for
the cluster icon assets.
Note those should probably
be PNGs and JPEGs as well.
With that, you can
just instantiate
a marker cluster given
the map to the markers
in these options.
And you get an example
just like this.
So already, I'm able to see
where a lot of the action
is in Australia.
And if I want, I can
choose to tunnel down
in different spaces.
But in this demo, I'm just
moving the map around violently
just to show that the
map is interactive even
with this additional
clustering logic on top.
So if you want to know
more about Maps clusters,
you can go to the short link.
There's one thing
that you should note--
we have changed
these short links.
We now have the E
after the goo.gl.
So now it's the
full kind of Google
with a dot in the middle.
So take that as a note.
And just to recap, we've
talked about custom overlays.
We want to add
and remove content
when the map isn't moving.
You don't want to have
heavyweight operations
in your draw methods.
For markers, you
want to consider
using markers instead of
custom overlays if possible.
Use JPEG and PNG assets
as opposed to SVGs.
And don't forget to cluster.
But we've talked about
what you can do now,
but I'm sure there's a few
of you there wondering what's
next, especially if you
are a developer that
has a lot of data
that you want to show.
You're probably
saying, Travis, it's
very nice and fun that
you showed an example
where you are rendering
1,000 markers on the map.
But I have to be
honest with you.
I have hundreds of
thousands of data
that I want to see on the map.
I might have millions of things
I want to show on the map.
What do you have for me?
So I'd like to announce
that we officially
have a partnership with the
great folk over a Deck.GL.
For those that do not
know what Deck.GL is,
it is an open source data
visualization library.
It uses WebGL on
client side to render
huge amounts of data sets
overlaid on top of a base map.
That base map can
be your Google Map.
So Deck.GL has a number
of layer examples
that you can read up more on.
But this example
here is an arc layer,
where there are arcs connecting
a star point and an end point.
And the arc is a 3D arc that
actually goes into the screen.
So in this example, this is
an arc layer of around 16,000
New York City cab pickups.
I'll just zoom in
just so you can
see that there are a bunch
of lines in this example.
We probably would have a
better visualization experience
if we offer tilt. Sad to say,
Google Maps on the JavaScript
platform does not support tilt--
at least not yet.
I also-- see, I like flights, so
I have another flight example.
This is an example of animating
the flight paths around London.
So this starts to show you
a little bit of the power
that you have when you pair
Deck.GL with Google Maps.
Whether or not you want a
static dynamic visualization
experience or you want more
of a dynamic animated data
visualization experience,
this Deck.GL and Google Maps
partnership is a
stepping stone to get you
where you want to be.
So how does this look in code?
This is very similar
to a standard example
of just incorporating the map.
You have an [? idea ?]
for your map.
I'm including the latest
Deck.GL JavaScript binary.
You also have a canvas for
the Deck.GL experience.
That will be overlaid
on top of the map.
I have some constants here that
just define different camera
properties.
In this example, the
pitch is set to zero.
That's because Google Maps
does not support tilt yet.
Once again, at least not yet.
One of the challenges
that Deck.GL and Google
Maps had to overcome in
making this partnership work
is reconciling between two
different camera models.
Now, we will continue to work
on this as time progresses.
But for the short term, you need
to apply a zoom level offset
for the Google Map camera.
And that's actually just one.
On this example, I'm also
supplying just a sample
type of URL to GeoJSON data.
I'll talk about what
GeoJSON is a bit later.
And from that, you can
initialize the map, very
similar to what you already do.
You apply the camera zoom
offset for your Google Map.
You create a new Deck.GL
experience with a deck canvas.
You pass in that same view state
minus the camera zoom offset.
In this example, I'm
disabling rotation.
Deck.GL supports
camera rotation.
Google Maps does not--
at least not yet.
And there is a callback for when
the Deck.GL view state changes.
And essentially, it just
tells the map to follow suit.
In addition to
this, you can supply
a number of Deck.GL layers
to overlay on the canvas.
And this one is a GeoJSON layer.
And for those that aren't
familiar with GeoJSON,
it is a geospatial data
format akin to KML.
For those in the GIS
community that know of KML,
you can incorporate points and
lines and polygonal geometry
to render on top of the map.
So with this GeoJSON
layer and Deck.GL,
you can supply the URL to
where every Deck.GL file is.
And there are various
parameters that you can use
to customize the experience.
But I'll show you a link
to documentation on where
you can dive deeper into that.
But right now I want to
switch to a live demo.
So in this demo, this is
showing earthquake data
in the West Coast.
And you're probably
saying, Travis,
there's not a lot
of earthquakes.
But as you zoom out,
you start to see that we
have tens of thousands of--
sorry, I actually clicked on
one of the hurricanes here.
But we have tens of
thousands of points.
And this is actually being
rendered interactively
on client side, using Deck.GL.
This demo-- just want to give
a shout-out to the great people
over at Ubilabs.
They are the ones that
created this demo.
So thank you to them.
And with that, I'll just
go back and transition back
to the slides.
So here is a short
link that can give you
insight on how to incorporate
Deck.GL and Google Maps
into your web applications.
Remember, we [INAUDIBLE]
to this link.
But this partnership was the
beginning of bringing WebGL
to the JS Google Maps API.
But in all honesty, we
really need your help here
because we want to continue
our investment in WebGL.
We want to offer more
to you as developers.
So we want to call
for your ideas.
We really want to
know how you feel
WebGL can enable new
types of features
that your users
can benefit from.
So whether or not you're
looking at maps on google.com
and you zoom down and you
see the spherical globe,
or if you're looking at the 3D
imagery within maps.google.com,
or if you're using maps, zooming
in, going into 3D imagery,
and then transitioning
into Street View,
I just really want you
to think outside the box.
Think outside the confines that
we've had up to this point.
And really think about ways that
WebGL can empower your users.
So I'm going to pause a
little bit on this slide
because this is an action
item that I really want
the developers in this room and
those on Livestream and YouTube
to take.
I really want you to
go to this website.
This will be live
for about a month.
This will link you
to a form where
you can start to tell
us some of the ideas
you have on how we can actually
better use WebGL in our API
offerings to you and
what types of things
or classes of features
you would use them for.
So please join us
and go on this link
and provide us a
little insight on how
you think we should bring
WebGL to the future.
So we talked about
the web for a while.
I want to transition over
to Android for a second.
Congratulations.
You, as of right now,
are my beta testers
for the new Android Maps SDK.
Yay.
Congratulations.
Thank you very much.
But this SDK-- it's
a little different
from how we've historically
delivered SDKs to you.
So there is an action item here.
We are moving our SDK out
of Google Mobile Services.
And this would be a library that
you need to statically compile
into your apps.
So there is an action associated
with adopting and trying
out this beta.
But we've done it
for a few reasons.
So little known fact--
the Google Maps mobile app
and the Android Maps SDK
that we offer in our
platform before now
have been built on completely
different maps stacks.
And this new SDK, we're
actually rectifying that.
So now the Android Maps SDK
and the Google Maps mobile app
are both built on
the same map stack.
So this gives us our
path for delivering
more of the goodness out of
the Google Maps mobile app
and offering that to
you as developers.
I mentioned this when I said
we were moving our SDK out
of Google Mobile Services.
But a reasoning behind
that is to allow
us to have more frequent
virtual releases to you.
So our future releases where
we invest and add new features,
it will be outside of
Google Mobile Services,
and it'll be a
static SDK that you
need to compile into your app.
But a benefit to
you in this process,
outside of us having more
frequent releases to you,
is that now you can test out the
latest version of the Android
Maps SDK without pushing it
out to your full end user base.
We also are thinking a little
bit about your users on this.
So we want to save them money
when they're not on Wi-Fi.
So the map data that's used to
render the maps with this SDK
uses up to 60% less data.
And because we went through
the process of refactoring
a lot of our SDK so that we
were built on the same stack
that the Google Maps mobile app
is built on, in that process
we closed 65 external issues.
You can look at
the issue tracker
and see which
issues were handled.
So I'm going to pause again.
Here's a link to
a migration guide.
We need your help.
We need your help here.
I repeat-- we need
your help here.
We want you to go to this site,
read up on the migration docs,
and actually test out this
SDK within your products.
If you see bugs, let us know
so we can fix them quickly.
But please, once again, go
to this migration guide.
Read up on how to
incorporate the new maps
SDK into your Android apps.
And let us know how it goes.
So we've circled through a
number of different things.
But I want to talk
about the future.
So in the past, we've
focused on building,
and we'll continue to
grow various industries
from the ridesharing industry to
travel to real estate and more.
But now we need to
focus on the industries
that you want to build.
So let's build those
industries together.
And you can start this
week by meeting this
for our office hours
tomorrow at 11:30 AM
and on Thursday at 12:30 PM.
And you can also catch us in the
Sandbox with our cloud partners
in the Cloud Dome.
So with that, I'd like to
thank you for your time.
For those in the audience,
Those in Livestream and
those watching on YouTube,
I appreciate every moment of it.
Take care.
[MUSIC PLAYING]